Daredevil is back – but a little different,
this time.
As exciting as it is to see Jennifer Walters
as the green-tinted She-Hulk: Attorney at
Law, there's another jurist hero that fans
are likewise eager to see turn up in the new Disney+ series.
As teased in trailers leading up to the latest
chapter in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
the MCU's newest lawyer is set to face off
against a familiar one: Matt Murdock, also
known as Daredevil, played once again by Charlie
Cox from the Netflix "Daredevil" series.
Following his appearance in "Spider-Man: No
Way Home"…
"I'm a really good lawyer."
…the final trailer for "She-Hulk: Attorney
at Law" confirmed that Murdock would re-emerge
as the horn-headed vigilante fans fell in
love with during his stint on his Netflix series.
The writers of "She-Hulk" made a daring move
introducing the hero of Hell's Kitchen, Director
Kat Coiro told Entertainment Weekly,
"I am definitely excited for Daredevil to
make his appearance, because I think he's
going to be a crowd favorite."
But it turns out the devil was in the details
regarding Murdock's return.
One detail, specifically.
Speaking to Lifehacker, "She-Hulk" writer
Jessica Gao revealed that Marvel gave the
creative team a surprising level of freedom
when they put in their request for Matt Murdock
to appear on the series.
She explained,
"When they first told us that [Daredevil]
was a possibility, we just couldn't believe it.
And as we were coming up with story and what
we wanted him to do, the fact that they kept
not saying no was shocking to us."
The one area that the writers got no say in
was Daredevil's costume.
Gao said,
"The one thing that I didn't have control
of was the suit.
They knew exactly what they wanted the suit
to look like."
From what we've seen so far, Daredevil's current
appearance does largely match the costume
Charlie Cox wore in the Netflix series, but
the extra bit of flair comes from the inclusion
of yellow, which is a callback to the color
combo that debuted in Daredevil's first six
issues, before he switched to all red.
Gao told Collider that many characters were
unavailable for inclusion in "She-Hulk" due
to conflicts with other MCU properties.
At first, she assumed that the same was true
of Daredevil, but the writing team soon found out otherwise.
Gao said,
"We thought we were being pranked.
We just kept writing him in, and we kept rolling
with the story just thinking like, 'Okay,
any moment now they're going to tell us we
can't use them.
They made a mistake.
They actually don't have the rights.'
But it just kept [becoming] more and more
real."
In July of 2022, Marvel Studios revealed that
it's in the process of working on a new Daredevil
series titled "Daredevil: Born Again."
It's entirely possible that his appearance
in "She-Hulk" will serve as a prelude to his
upcoming starring vehicle.
Could the fact that his suit is now somewhat
different in appearance suggest we're dealing
with a different devil than the one who exclaimed
in 2018,
"I beat you!"
…or is this merely a new chapter for an
established character?
We'll leave Jen to find that out as "She-Hulk"
continues.